༼སྔན་མ་སྔན་མ་༽ "Bim"གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད།
འོ་དེ་ནང་ལ་དགྲ་རྒོད་གཅིག་་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)་འོ་དེས་"Bim"ལ་རྡོག་རྒྱག་གཅིག་ཞུས་རེད། [ཨ་ལོ་]སྐྲངས་རེད་མགོ་ལ།
གཞན་པ།
[ཨ་ལོད་]སྐྲངས་ནས་དགྲ་རྒོད་ལ་ཆུ་གཅིག་གཤུད་རེད།
ཆུ་གང་ཚང་གཅིག་གཤུད་རེད་(ད)་
༼ཨི་འདྲའི་༽འདྲ་བོ་གསུམ་གཤུད་རེད།
"Bim" ༼གིས་༽༼ར་༽་
"Bim" ༼གིས་༽༼ར་༽༼རྐང་སུག་༽(ད་)ཧམ་གོག་དེ་གནམ་ལ་གཡུག་རེད
ང་མར་བསྡད་བསྡད་རེད། [ཨ་རམ་]བྱས་ནས།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽གས་ཡོད་མ་རེད།
ངས་བཟོ་དགོས་བྱས། ངས་ངན་པོ་དཔེ་བཟོ་༼གི་༽རེད་(ད)།དེ་ལ་གཅིག་བྱས་
དེ་མ་རེད། དང་པོ་སྔོན་ལ་དེ་གཉིས་བཞག་དགོས་(ར)།
༼ཨི་འདྲའི་༽བཞག་དགོས། ཨོ་ཧ་གོ་སོང་། དེ་དེ་ལ་༼ཨི་འདྲའི་༽བཞག་དེ།
སྒེའུ་ཁུང་ལ་སྒར་༼ཡ་༽གཅིག་པོ་མ་རེད་(ད)།
དེ་༼ཨི་འདྲའི་༽གཅིག་སྒོ་ལ། དེ་
བཞག་ཤོག དེ་བཟོ་ཚར་ན་འདི་
འདི་༼ཨི་འདྲའི་༽བྱས། འདི་གཉིས་གཉིས་མཉམ་དུ་༼ཨི་འདྲའི་༽བྱས་ནས་སྒར་༼ཡ་༽རེད།
སྙིང་རྗེ་མོ་ཆགས་༼གི་༽རེད། ར། དེ་ཚོ་ཚང་མ་སྤྲད་(ད)།
ཨ་ལས་དང་པོ། རྗེས་ལ་འདི་གཅིག་བྱེད་(ར་)སྙིང་རྗེ་མོ་་་སྙིང་རྗེ་མོ་ཆགས་༼གི་༽རེད་(ད)།འདི་ཚོ་གཅིག་ལྟ་(ད་)འདི་
འདི། འདི་ཚོ།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽སྙིང་རྗེ་མོ་་་སྙིང་རྗེ་མོ་ཆགས་(ར)། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽འདི་གཉིས་གཉིས་གཅིག་སྒར་(ད)།
༼ཨི་འདྲའི་༽ཨ་མ་རང་མ་སྒར་(ད)། ང་འདི་སྒར་སྙིང་བྲོ་སོང་།
སྙིང་རྗེ་མོ།
ཧ་གོ་མ་སོང་།
བཞག་དགོས་མ་རེད། མ་བྱེད་(ད)། ༼ཨི་འདྲའི་༽ལབ་མེད། ༼ཨི་འདྲའི༽།
འདི་་
འདི་སྙིང་རྗེ་མོ་བཟོ་དགོས་བས།
སྙིང་རྗེ་མོ་བཟོ་རེད་(ད)།
འདི། ཨ་མ་འདི་ག་འདྲས་བཟོ་དགོས་རེད།
འདི་སྙིང་རྗེ་མོ་ཆགས་སོང་(ང་)།
ཨ་མ་མགོ་ནས་གཅིག་ལེན་ག ང་བཟོ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
འདི་་རྨ་བཟོ་སོང་(ང་)།
སྐར་མ་སྒུགས་ཨ། ང་གཅིག་བཞག་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
འདི་ལ་༼ཨི་འདྲའི་༽བཞག་དགོས་རེད་འདི།
སྐར་མ་གཅིག་འདི། འདི་ཨ་མ་འདི་༼ཨི་འདྲའི་༽གཅིག་བཞག་དགོས་རེད།
འདི་
ངས་གཅིག་བཟོ། ངས་གཅིག་བཟོ་དགོས་བྱས།
འདི། འདི། ༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽བྱས།
ཨ་མ་རང་དཔེ་སྦོ་ཤོབ་ཡོད་(ད)། ངས་སྙིང་རྗེ་བོ་གཅིག་བཟོས་༼དུས་བསམ་པ་༽བཤིག་གི་རེད་(ད)།དཔེ་མདོག་ངན་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)་(ལོ)།
ཡོད་མ་རེད་(ལོ)། རྫུན་མ་ལབ་༼གི་༽འདུག(ལོ)།
འདི། ༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽བཟོ་ཐུབ་ཀྱི༼ཁོ་ར་༽མེད་(བ)། འདི་༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽བཟོ་ཐུབ་ཀྱི་མེད་(བ)།
༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽བཟོ་ཐུབ་ཀྱི་མེད་བ་།
འདི་་༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽བཟོ་ཐུབ་ཀྱི་མེད་(བ)། དེ་ད་གོབ་ཏོ་རེད།
ག་རེ།
མ་ལེན་(ད)། ངས་སྙིང་རྗེ་པོ་བཟོ་༼གི་༽ཡོད།
ཨ་མ་ལ་[ཡོའོ་]མང་པོ་འདུག་(ད)། [ཡོའོ་]མ་རབས་འདུག་(ད)། ག་བ་ལ།
འདི་་༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽བཟོ༼ཁོ་ར་༽ཐཱུབ་༼གི་༽མེད་(བ)།
ཨ་མ་གཅིག་འདི། འདི
འདི། བཟོ་ཐུབ་ཀྱི་ཡོད་བས།
བཟོ༼ཁོ་ར་༽ཐུབ་ཀྱི་མ་རེད་(ད)།ད་དུང་ང་ལ་༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽ལབ། ཁང་པ་བཟོས་(ད)།
འདི་༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽བཟོ།
སྐར་མ་གཅིག ཧ་གོ་སོང་འདི་༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽སྙིང་རྗེ་མོ་གཅིག་བཟོ་དགོས།
འདི་༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽བཟོ་ཐུབ་༼གི་༽མེད་(བ)།
སླེབས་༼དུས་བསམ་པ་༽ང་རྫིགས་པོ་གཅིག་བཟོ་སྡོད་ཀྱི་ཡོད་རེད།
ཨ་མ་སླེབས་༼དུས་བསམ་པ་༽ངས་རྫིགས་པོ་གཅིག་བཟོས་ཚར་རེད།
འདི་བལྟ་དང་།
༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽རེད་འདི།
འདི་བཟོས་སོང་(ང་)།
ང་སྙིང་རྗེ་པོ་ཞིག་བཟོ་དགོས་ཡོད།
ང་གཅིག་བཟོ་གི ང་ཁང་པ་བཟོ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
གས་བསྡད་༼གི་༽མ་རེད།
ཨ་མ་འགྲོ་ཚར་ཡིན་པས།
ཨ་མ་འགྲོ་ཚར་ཡིན་པས། ཨ་མ་ལགས།
གཅིན་པ་བཏང་ཚར་ཡིན་པས། བཏང་ཚར་ཡིན་པས།
ཁང་པ་བཟོས་(ད)།
ང་ཁང་པ་བཟོས་(ད)།